und jetzt das heute journal
mit kaiser richter und christian sievers
guten abend hinein ein deutsches
exportmodell steht vor einem ganz großen
stresstest das system der kurzarbeit
eine art brücke die uns schon durch
wirtschaftskrisen hindurch geleitet hat
und die diverse länder von deutschland
übernommen haben muss jetzt zeigen was
es kann
die deutschen unternehmen haben gut zehn
millionen anträge auf kurzarbeit
gestellt das gab es noch nie und das
heißt fast jeder dritte beschäftigte in
deutschland ist von kurzarbeit bedroht
in manchen branchen sind es bereits
jetzt drei viertel der mitarbeiter
das heißt konkret die beschäftigten
müssten auf einen teil ihres geldes
verzichten die firmen im gegenzug ihre
mitarbeiter halten und ein lohnausgleich
kommt von der arbeitsagentur
deren chef ist heute anzusehen wie sehr
ihn das alles mitnimmt dominik
löschmeister berichtet seit über einem
monat stillstand im opel werk in
rüsselsheim
die meisten der 17.000 deutschen opel
mitarbeiter sind in kurzarbeit wie auch
sonst in der automobilindustrie
deutschlands wohlstands motor gestoppt
das soll sich bald ändern
also der wiederanlauf ist ganz wichtig
auch für die in der produktion das man
das als signal auch sieht für die
mitarbeiter aber auch für die wirtschaft
insgesamt weil man natürlich sehen kann
dass man dann auch wieder ein stück
normalität in den alltag bekommt fieber
messen am eingang masken pflicht
einbahnstraßen in den gebäuden sogar ein
teil der sitze der raucherecke haben sie
abmontiert das ziel so wenig kontakte
wie möglich und wir haben dafür gesorgt
dass die mitarbeiter in ihrer station
verbleiben und dass er sich sozusagen
dort nicht begegnen werden dass
arbeitsablauf das heißt die station sind
entkoppelt so dass für den ein meter
fünfzig abstand einhalten
es ist die produktion wieder reibungslos
läuft wie auf diesen bildern vor corona
werden noch wochen vergehen
deutschlands betriebe melden für den
april über zehn millionen menschen in
kurzarbeit
detlef scheele der chef der
bundesagentur für arbeit bisher positive
meldungen gewöhnt spricht von einem
arbeitsmarkt unter druck
wir sind ein drittel aller betriebe die
kurzarbeit angemeldet haben
wir wissen noch nicht wieviel
kurzarbeiter es in den abrechnungen am
ende des tages sind das werden wir aber
auch demnächst wissen und es ist dazu
nahezu 100% corona als ursache auch die
zahl der arbeitslosen geht nach oben im
april waren zwei millionen 644.000
menschen ohne job die arbeitslosenquote
liegt bei 5,8 prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat eine steigerung um
415.000 die entwicklung zeigte könnens
wir unser land auch in unserem land
nicht für jeden arbeitsplatz garantieren
aber wir werden weiter um jeden job
kämpfen
doch nicht überall in deutschland ist
die wirtschaft von kurzarbeit betroffen
im sachsen werk in dresden sind die
auftragsbücher voll
der maschinenbauer produziert mittel und
hochspannungs antriebe hat aktuell
genügend beschäftigung wir haben viele
branchen in der wirtschaft in der wir
vertreten sind die es uns also
ermöglichen unterschiede oder
schwankende einzel konjunkturen den
märkten auszugleichen
und wir haben viele langlauf projekte
vor allen dingen auch bei uns im bereich
bei den großmaschinen die schon lange
bestellt sind früher haben thomas
richter und seine mitarbeiter auf
corinna reagiert haben feste teams in
der produktion gebildet doch ein
weiterer stillstand hätte auch
auswirkungen auf der sachsen werde ich
denke für die nächste zeit jetzt habe
ich diesen schritt dass wir wieder
anfangen stabile logistikketten
aufzubauen dass wir sicherheit haben
dass auch unsere kundschaft sicherheit
hat damit projekte angeschoben werden
damit auf folgeprojekte entsprechend
entstehen
die unternehmen wollen so schnell es
geht zurück in den normalzustand
doch die wirtschaftskrise könnte
heftiger werden bei zehn millionen
menschen in kurzarbeit
reiner hoffmann chef des dgb
deutschlands oberster gewerkschaftler
guten abend herr hoffmann
guten abend herr sievers hofmann wenn
sie diese unfassbar hohen
kurzarbeiterzahlen sehen was löst das
bei ihnen aus es zeigt welchen
erheblichen druck wie auf dem
arbeitsmarkt haben
aber es zeigt auch dass die kurzarbeit
ganz maßgeblich dazu beiträgt dass wir
beschäftigung sichern und menschen nicht
arbeitslos werden
jetzt hat dieses system der
arbeitsagentur im moment 26 milliarden
euro rücklagen zum glück muss man sagen
aber auch die werden natürlich nicht so
wahnsinnig lange reichen wenn das jetzt
so weitergeht kann das kurzarbeiter
system diese krise stemmen
ich gehe davon aus dass ist diese krise
stemmen kann die kasse sie haben es
gesagt der bundesagentur ist gut gefüllt
es hängt natürlich vom verlauf der krise
ab und wann es uns gelingt wieder einen
behutsam ein stich in das
gesellschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
leben zu organisieren und wie
umfangreich die kurzarbeit dann am ende
auch sein will aber grundsätzlich sind
wir gut gerüstet
haben sie den eindruck dass die
unternehmen jetzt im moment die
kurzarbeit mit augenmaß an wänden und
anmelden
oder sehen sie da auch firmen die das
jetzt möglicherweise ausnutzen und die
kosten abwälzen
für probleme die ihn so oder so
entstanden werden wir haben eine ganz
unterschiedliche situation auf dem
arbeitsmarkt wir wissen dass stätten
restaurants sind seit langem geschlossen
da findet keine arbeit statt ich gehe
davon aus dass die arbeitgeber das
instrument behutsam nutzen und ein
eigenes interesse daran haben dass die
beschäftigung sichern weil in ein paar
wochen hoffe ich dass wir aus der krise
wieder auch langsam in fahrt kommen und
dann brauchen sie ihre fachkräfte
sie müssen sie dann nicht wieder neu
einstellen deshalb gehe ich davon aus
dass wird behutsam auch von den
arbeitgebern genutzt missbrauch
natürlich nicht ausgeschlossen
die meisten unternehmenszahlen sehen ja
wirklich düster aus das gibt's das ganze
branchen den brechen praktisch komplett
alle umsätze weg das bedeutet er für
sehr hofft man dass sie sich in den
nächsten tarifrunden bereits auf einen
satz einstellen werden müssen nämlich
den für tariferhöhungen ist jetzt
absolut keine zeit und kein platz was
antworten sie da haben wir gezeigt in
den tarifrunden der letzten wochen viele
sind ausgesetzt wurden verschoben worden
und wir gehen davon aus dass wir nach
dem sommer dann auch wieder perspektive
haben und dass wir dann auch wieder die
wirtschaft in gang setzen und deshalb
gibt es überhaupt keinen grund jetzt
schon enger zu schnallen sondern lassen
sie uns behutsam dazu dafür sorgen dass
wir möglichst rasch wieder in ein
normalbetrieb kommen und das müssen dann
auch arbeitnehmer wieder angemessen an
den wirtschaftlichen erfolgen der
unternehmen beteiligt wäre da sind sie
natürlich jetzt sehr sehr optimistisch
bis lang in den letzten jahren hitziger
motto immer am aufschwung teilhaben muss
jetzt auch gelten im abschwung mitleiden
sozusagen
nein es geht nicht um mitleid sondern es
geht um verantwortung und verantwortung
besteht in allererster linie darin dass
wir jetzt alles unternehmen um
beschäftigung zu sichern
wir brauchen das ist absehbar
konjunkturelle stützungsmaßnahmen damit
die wirtschaft wieder in gang gesetzt
wird und dann gehe ich auch davon aus
dass arbeitnehmer dann ihren anteil
bekommen und dass wir doch gerade jetzt
auch in der krise sehen wie wichtig
betriebspersonal räte sind wenn es darum
geht die voraussetzungen dass wir wieder
unter bedingungen dass der
gesundheitsschutz der arbeit schon
sicher gestellt wird wie der fahrt
aufnehmen können
das ist verantwortung die übernehmen wir
und dann schauen wir mal wie wir ein
paar wochen da stehen ich bin der verein
optimistisch was wir im moment auch
seien in dieser krise ist wie gut an
vielen stellen
home office funktioniert tatsächlich das
probieren immer mehr firmen aus jetzt
zwangsläufig
gleichzeitig ist es so dass diese
multinationalen digital unternehmen die
auch vor der krise schon sehr im
aufschwung waren dass die jetzt
natürlich noch einmal enorm profitieren
und sich die hände reiben
wie wird unsere arbeitswelt nach corona
aussehen sie wird mit sicherheit
digitaler sein
der dgb hat schon seit langem einen
rechtsanspruch auf mobiles arbeiten
gefordert das findet jetzt in einem
großen umfang statt wir müssen aber auch
acht geben dass mobiles aber nicht zu
entgrenzung führt dass keine mehrarbeit
geleistet wird die am ende des tages
nicht bezahlt wird wir müssen
rahmenbedingungen schaffen wo mobiles
arbeiten denn auch gutes arbeiten ist
hoffmann morgen ist der erste meiner an
das ist beruflich zumindest für sie der
wichtigste tag im jahr in ihrem kalender
aber wie durchsetzungsstark kann eine
gewerkschaftsbewegung sein die ihre
forderungen morgen nur virtuell
mitteilen kann
die durchsetzungsfähigkeit der deutschen
gewerkschaften dies natürlich jeden tag
gegeben aber sie haben recht der erste
mai ist ein internationaler feiertag der
internationale tag der arbeit wir haben
sehr früh entschieden dass wir unter den
bedingungen der korona pandemie in
diesem jahr nicht auf den straßen und
plätzen dem uns demonstrieren sondern
wir haben uns entschieden dass wir
online gehen ins netz gehen
solidarität heißt in diesem jahr abstand
halten und wir werden mit einem sehr
spannenden kurzweiligen live programm ab
11 uhr auf sendung sein
ich kann allen nur einladen schauen sie
bei uns rein das wird sicherlich
interessant und sie hoffen dann dass
ganz viele dabei sind genauso viele wie
sonst auf den straßen wären ja ich gehe
davon aus dass wir den riesen zuspruch
bekommen wir haben wirklich ein tolles
programm wir haben viel unterstützung
aus der politik aus der kultur
wir haben lebendige beiträge von
betroffenen menschen und wir werden
natürlich auch den ersten morgen dafür
nutzen dass wir unsere perspektiven von
arbeit der zukunft sozialer
gerechtigkeit in den mittelpunkt stellen
ein besonderer erster morgen rainer
hoffmann dgb-chef herzlichen dank nicht
an genesis unser nächstes thema es hat
fast schon etwas von
ritual die bundeskanzlerin bespricht
sich mit den ministerpräsidenten der
länder und hinterher erfahren die
deutschen wie ihr tägliches leben in
weiteren corona zeiten aussehen kann
soll muss dabei hat die politik wie wir
alle die aktuellen zahlen zur
entwicklung der pandemie im auge und die
sehen heute so aus tests haben mehr als
162.000 infektionen bestätigt das sind
die aktuellen zahlen der
johns-hopkins-universität davon sind 123
1500 menschen inzwischen wieder genesen
6500 18 menschen starben
in verbindung mit cupid 19 die
reproduktions zahl die das robert koch
institut errechnet hat liegt bei 0,76
das bedeutet zehn infizierte stecken
rein rechnerisch im schnitt zwischen
sieben und acht weitere menschen an
ja das ist die basis auf der jetzt
beschlossen ist es soll weitere
erleichterungen geben und zwar nach
bundesweit einheitlichen grundsätzen
aber es zeigt sich auch der teufel liegt
im detail florian a
wie kompliziert etwa die spielplatz
frage ist zeigt sich heute nicht nur im
kanzleramt sondern auch zehn fußminuten
davon entfernt diese rutsche im berliner
tiergarten seit dem morgen offiziell
eröffnet dieser spielplatz hier anderer
stadtteil bis zum abend noch dicht
manche sperrung endet erst nächste woche
wenn sich schon zwölf berliner bezirke
nicht auf ein einheitliches vorgehen
einigen können
wie soll das dann 16 ministerpräsidenten
und kanzlerin gelingen
auch wenn die später noch das ziel so
vorgibt
ich glaube es ist damit interessen der
menschen der bürgerinnen und bürger dass
es für ganz deutschland eine strategie
gibt also strategie suche per
videoschalte die erste nach merkels
kritik an manchen länderchefs und ihrer
umsetzung der maßnahmen
sie wirkt auf mich in teilen sehr forsch
um nicht zu sagen zuvor die große
eröffnungs diskussion aber verschoben
auf nächste woche
es regiert prinzip vorsicht denn ihr
wisst nicht was kommt denn solange kein
medikament kein impfstoff da ist droht
jederzeit die gefahr eines rückfalls
oder einer zweiten welle und so
diskutieren sie offenbar länger über die
spielplatz strategie entscheiden sich
sofort wenn man sein für die öffnung
auch gottesdienste sollen unter strengen
auflagen erlaubt werden so will man
wieder öffnen museen ebenfalls so viel
zur einheitlichen strategie die aber
auch darin besteht keine einheit zu
wahren
wir haben eine unterschiedliche
betroffenheit in deutschland und es gibt
in manchen regionen noch lokale
ereignisse die besondere maßnahmen
erforderlich machen
und deshalb wird es von der dänischen
grenze und der ost- und nordseeküste im
norden bis hin zu den alpen
unterschiedliche regeln auch geben noch
keine regeln vor allem aber keine
termine gibt es für kitas und
grundschulen
das wolle man erst nächste woche prüfen
familien dürfen nicht die verlierer der
krise seien und deshalb ist das heutige
treffen und die ergebnisse eine
enttäuschung
wir erwarten dass mit priorität für
bildung und wirtschaft
planungssicherheit geschaffen wird dass
jetzt die zeit genutzt wird die offenbar
den letzten wochen nicht genügend
genutzt wurde
bleibt die frage nach dem sommerurlaub
zum beispiel in südeuropa lieber noch
nicht buchen heißt es dazu heute
und außerdem wenn überhaupt dann doch
lieber in deutschland wenn man nicht im
süden fährt und kann man da in bayern
hat auch super möglichkeiten
damit ist schon geklärt oder südwesten
der westen nicht dabei sagt markus söder
zufällig etwa das land von armin laschet
für kleine spitzen ist immer noch zeit
ja mehr zum bund länder treffen
außerhalb der urlaubs frage
nachher in der sendung aber erst hat
keine server die weitere nachrichtenwelt
im überblick bundesinnenminister
seehofer verbietet alle aktivitäten der
islamistischen hisbollah in deutschland
ihre anhänger dürfen sich nicht mehr
versammeln oder ihre symbole zeigen
in mehreren bundesländern durchsuchten
hunderte beamte moscheen und vereine der
bewegung die hisbollah bestreitet das
existenzrecht israels ihr bewaffneter
arm wird von der eu als
terrororganisation eingestuft in
deutschland soll sie unter anderem
spenden für ihre aktivitäten sammeln
thüringens verfassungsschutzpräsident
kammer glaubt nicht an die
selbstauflösung des afg flügels der
angekündigte schritt sei eine bewusste
taktische nebelkerze sagte er dem mdr
das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
hatte den flügel mitte märz als
rechtsextrem eingestuft und unter
beobachtung gestellt der afw vorstand
hatte daraufhin die auflösung der
inoffiziellen gruppierung verlangt mit
stichtag heute krankenkassen dürfen
vorerst weiter namentlich unkenntlich
gemachte patientendaten für
forschungszwecke weitergeben
das hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
entschieden und damit einen eilantrag
eines versicherten zurückgewiesen
allerdings wollen die richter die neuen
befugnisse der kassen kritisch prüfen
ende 2009 10 hatte der bundestag grünes
licht dafür gegeben dass bestimmte
gesundheitsdaten wie
medikamenteneinnahmen zentral gesammelt
und ausgewertet werden dürfen
am 10 mai sollen die polen ein neues
staatsoberhaupt werden trotz der korona
krise allerdings wächst der druck den
termin zu verschieben
mehrere frühere staats und
regierungschefs des landes riefen die
bürger zum boykott auf während die
opposition eine verschiebung fordert
hält die regierung an dem termin fest
ihr kandidat gilt derzeit als favorit
geplant ist eine reine briefwahl
und die korona panne wirkt sich auch auf
die zahl der asylbewerber in europa aus
wegen verschärfter grenzkontrollen und
einreiseverbote gegen sie deutlich
zurück im märz registrierten die eu und
vier weitere europäische länder etwas
mehr als 34.000 asylanträge 43 prozent
weniger als im februar
die meisten antragsteller kamen demnach
weiterhin aus afghanistan syrien und
kolumbien wenn die politik
einschränkungen beschließt und die
gesellschaft sich auf harte zeiten
einstellen dann gibt es teile dieser
gesellschaft die niemand fragt die keine
stimme haben und keine mächtige lobby
organisation auf ihrer seite
unsere kinder besonders die ganz jungen
und das obwohl gerade sie das leben in
corona zeiten noch mal speziell trifft
sie spüren da ändert sich so viel und
sie verstehen so wenig wie auch wenn
selbst die erwachsenen lauter
fragezeichen im kopf haben und jeden tag
neu lernen müssen
susan von lojewski hat mit klarer insa
und benjamin gesprochen stellvertretend
für millionen gleichaltrige klarer ist
eigentlich ein aufgewecktes kleines
mädchen ihre mutter ist ärztin darf ihr
kind weiter in die kita bringen
doch da ist nichts wie gewohnt kein
trubel wenig spielkameraden immerhin
ihre beste freundin insa ist auch da die
welt der fünfjährigen aber hat sich
verändert
aber die oma und opa kinder machen sich
viele gedanken warum ist alles so wie es
ist und wie lange wird es dauern
fragen die auch kleine menschen sich
stellen und die sie belasten
ich finde den kindern wird schon viel
abverlangen zu von jetzt auf gleich eine
neue situation mit der sie so zurecht
kommen müssen die meisten kinder so
sagen experten sehen sich selbst in der
korona krise nur als belastung weil sie
betreut beschäftigt bekocht werden
müssen
dabei ist auch ihre kleine welt aus den
fugen geraten ohne dass sie darüber
reden
das sehen wir auch in normalen zeiten
dass kinder sehr rücksichtsvoll sind und
oft sehr lange ihre psychische belastung
zurückhaltend die eltern dazu schon
versuchen und das versuchen mit sich
selbst auszumachen und das ist jetzt in
dieser zeit natürlich nochmals schärfer
nicht mehr reden auch wenn gerade das
jetzt wichtig wäre erst recht mit
anderen menschen als den eigenen eltern
benjamin der zu einer routine
untersuchung ins krankenhaus musste
vermisst seinen kindergarten nicht
wirklich aber dass er seine großeltern
nicht mehr sehen darf das beschäftigt
ihn schon für benjamins kinderarzt
andreas eberle ist klar
kinder brauchen schnell wieder
sozialkontakte außerhalb der eigenen
vier wände und sei es nur stundenweise
über 10 millionen kinder unter 14 jahren
gibt es in deutschland auch ihre rechte
sei nun wichtig kinder werden gerade zu
wenig gehört aber sie konnten auch zu
wenig gehört werden es wurden wichtige
und wesentliche entscheidungen getroffen
die einfach gemacht werden mussten aber
jetzt müssen wir in die zukunft schauen
und jetzt müssen wir die kinder wieder
mehr einbeziehen
es ist ein schwieriger balanceakt das
leben in diesen tagen nicht nur nach den
interessen der erwachsenen zu lenken
sondern auch die sorgen und wünsche der
kinder im blick zu behalten
die welt häufiger mal aus der
perspektive der ganz kleinen zu sehen
ist generell keine schlechte idee den
crooner überblick an diesem donnerstag
hat jetzt simone friedrich
großbritannien hat die zahl der toten
laut johns hopkins universität auf mehr
als 26.000 700 nach oben korrigiert in
die statistik sind nun auch todesfälle
aus pflegeheimen und privathaushalten in
england und wales aufgenommen
großbritannien hat damit die
zweithöchste zahl an toten in europa
nach italien
der medikamenten wirkstoff rennen die
sie wir können die genesung von kogit 19
patienten offenbar beschleunigen so das
ergebnis einer us-studie die patienten
hätten sich durchschnittlichen elf statt
15 tagen erholt ob es die sterberate
senken kann ist nicht klar
wissenschaftler warnen vor zu großen
erwartungen
kinder die mit dem corona virus
infiziert sind sind vermutlich genauso
ansteckend wie erwachsene berichten
forscher um den biologen drosten von der
berliner charité
sie warnen deshalb vor einer
uneingeschränkten schule und
kindergarten öffnung
die studie ist noch nicht von
unabhängigen experten geprüft
[Musik]
baden-württemberg mecklenburg-vorpommern
und thüringen haben beschlossen jetzt
auch geschäfte mit mehr als 800
quadratmetern fläche wieder zu öffnen
teils schon am samstag voraussetzung
sind allerdings schutzkonzepte
jetzt noch mal zurück zu den gesprächen
in sachen corona zwischen bund und
ländern jedes dieser treffen im
angesicht einer gemeinsamen bedrohung
für zu neuen fragen wird auch schon mal
zu stirnrunzeln aber es macht eben auch
klar das hier ist ein großes land mit
vielen unterschiedlichen
ausgangssituationen sorgen und nöten die
menschen im saarland sehen sich gerne
als teil einer familie und denken dabei
wenig an das ferne berlin und viel mehr
an ihren nachbarn in frankreich und
luxemburg
kein wunder also dass dort jetzt eine
diskussion läuft welche schäden für das
länderübergreifende familienleben die
geschlossenen grenzen anrichten und wie
viel diplomatisches fingerspitzengefühl
der saarländische innenminister in
dieser sache haben muss heute kommt die
nachricht ab sofort will das saarland
drei weitere grenzübergänge öffnen
außer brücken berichtet susanne freitag
als das saarland mitte märz seine grenze
dicht machte ging ein schock durch die
region
deutschland prescht vor im
infektionsschutz das saarland grenzt
sich ab vom französischen nachbarn und
dann fiel immer wieder einer auf
innenminister klaus bouillon der als
oberster polizist an der saar natürlich
auch die grenze sichern muss markige
worte immer wieder
bonn gilt als hardliner der auch mal
aneckt und konflikte nicht scheut auch
wenn sie grenzen überschreiten das sagte
er dem saarländischen rundfunk zunächst
aber geht es darum dass die franzosen
wissen wenn sie kommen
sie werden überprüfbaren punktuelle
kontrollen und wenn es gelingt jeden tag
einige zu finden die wir zurückliegen
dann haben wir das risiko minimiert die
pro tag gibt es nach wie vor 500
zurückweisungen es mag ich mir nicht
vorstellen was wäre wenn all diese
menschen zu uns gekommen werden so jung
ist zitiert worden auch bei uns mit
diesen sätzen aus dem handelsblatt
grenzschutz ist menschenschutz jeder
abgewiesene franzose bedeute ein stück
mehr sicherheit für die saarländer
heftige reaktionen im netz heiko maas
twitter dass solche aussagen nicht
akzeptabel seien ein affront gegen die
französischen nachbarn katarina barley
er hinterlässt einen scherbenhaufen
schreiben saarländer und erste stimmen
fordern seinen rücktritt
wo jung reagierte heute auf facebook den
satz mit dem er zitiert werde habe er so
nicht gesagt dennoch entschuldigt er
sich dafür dass seine äußerungen in der
letzten zeit zu missverständnissen
geführt haben
die spd groko partner im saarland
kritisiert bouillon schon seit langem
sie erwarten eine reaktion des
ministerpräsidenten
an dieser stelle muss der
ministerpräsident als cdu vorsitzender
und als ministerpräsident des landes das
letztlich bewerten
und er muss vor allem klarstellen dass
er nicht hinter einem solchen
gesamtauftritt steht und muss sich
deutlich distanzieren dass es die
erwartung der spd tobias ans verteidigte
seinen minister heute abend in einer
fernsehshow türlich habe ich mit klaus
pro jahr gesprochen er ist auch tief
betroffen dass zitate von ihm die jetzt
auch schon einige wochen zurück liegen
in der zeit hat sich etwas verändert und
das vor allem auch ein falsch
wiedergegebene zitat jetzt in dieser
form diskutiert wird und klaus brunner
bedauert es dass das auch zu einer
minderung unseres ansehens führen kann
reizthema grenze die franzosen waren
tief verletzt über die grenzschließung
und die äußerungen aus dem saarland
jetzt muss ruhe einkehren findet
christoph arendt der in frankreichs
nationalversammlung für die deutsch
französischen beziehungen zuständig ist
supercool yves rossy die torfrau es geht
hier nicht nur um franzosen
es gibt hier deutsche die in frankreich
leben franzosen die in deutschland leben
wir sind deutsch franzosen europäer die
gefahr das virus zu instrumentalisieren
ist groß sagt er und warnt vor
populismus den guten verhältnis an der
grenze schade
heute haben tobias hans und horst
seehofer erst einmal eine öffnung
weiterer grenzübergänge beschlossen
ein erster schritt in richtung
normalität in einer region in der man
die grenze fast vergessen hatte und wir
schauen noch mal auf die wirtschaftliche
seite der chor oder krise so sehr sie
manche wirtschaft zwei gebeutelt so sehr
verschafft sie anderen branchen
rückenwind zu erwarten viele it
unternehmen einen richtiggehenden
wachstumsschub schließlich ist der
computer im moment kino büro und
einkaufsladen in einem see nahe mainz in
frankfurt ja und noch vieles mehr
zugleich deshalb profitiert
mittelfristig vor allem die
digitalwirtschaft zwar vermutet der
verband der internetwirtschaft ein minus
von 1,2 prozent fürs laufende jahr aber
perspektivisch gesehen kann die branche
nach der korona krise auf steigende
wachstumszahlen setzen denn cora
beschleunigt die digitalisierung in
vielen bereichen unter anderem im handel
und in der logistik in den nächsten fünf
jahren wird erwartet dass die digitale
wirtschaft boomt bis zu zehn prozent
jährlich könnten die steigerungsraten
seien besonders digital aufgerüstet wird
in den bereichen bildung gesundheit und
public cloud services also digitale
speicherdienste rosige aussichten also
für die digitale wirtschaft weniger
rosig waren die aussichten heute am
deutschen aktienmarkt der dax verliert
vor dem langen wochenende mehr als zwei
prozent und beendet den handel mit
10.000 862 punkten
am nachmittag kam das - passend zu den
aktuellen arbeitslosenzahlen aus den usa
seit ausbruch der korona krise haben
dort 30 millionen amerikaner einen
erstantrag auf arbeitslosenhilfe
gestellt
die usa sind in sachen digitalisierung
schon mehrere schritte weiter als
deutschland
es gilt jetzt nicht den anschluss zu
verpassen wir haben es vorhin gehört
selbst der erste mai morgen der tag der
arbeit wird beim deutschen
gewerkschaftsbund digital gefeiert
dieses mal vielen dank an die börse
in diesen skandal hat der bundesverband
der verbraucherzentralen seine muster
feststellungsklage gegen vw
zurückgenommen
grund ist ein groß angelegter vergleich
mit dem autobauer
30.000 anträge hat vw nach eigenen
angaben bereits positiv geprüft 17.000
fälle würden noch bearbeitet
die betroffenen kunden erhalten demnach
je nach fahrzeug zwischen 1350 und 6250
euro ab morgen müssen postkunden weniger
für private päckchen und pakete bezahlen
der konzern nimmt die preiserhöhung vom
ersten januar wieder zurück damit kostet
zum beispiel ein mittelgroßes päckchen
jetzt wieder vier euro 50 statt 4 euro
79 grund für den rückzieher ist ein
streit mit der bundesnetzagentur wie
sehr sich die pandemie auf verkehr und
wirtschaft auswirkt lässt sich auch an
der weltweiten luftqualität messen
die internationale energieagentur
verzeichnet den stärksten rückgang der
co2 emissionen den es je gegeben hat
insgesamt werde der treibhausgas ausstoß
in diesem jahr voraussichtlich um acht
prozent sinken
der weltweite energiebedarf um sechs
prozent experten gehen allerdings davon
aus dass der effekt nur kurzfristig ist
und jetzt ein runder geburtstag den ein
ganzes land feiert captain tom moore
britische veteran aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg wird 100 der mann ist zur
berühmtheit geworden in der korona krise
und zum vorbild 100 runden hat captain
mo durch seinen garten gezogen 1000
pfund wollte er so für pfleger und ärzte
sammeln
es wurden über 30 millionen pfund
weltrekord und anders für die luftwaffe
zu gratulieren
ich habe die ehre ihnen ein paar
glückwünsche und geschenke zu
überreichen
ein paar ist gut es sind über 125.000
geburtstagskarten darunter auch eine von
der queen und dann das zwei alte
spitfire information über seinem haus
großbritannien gratuliert und verneigt
sich und macht captain mo heute zum
kernel
damit lassen wir sie in diesen
donnerstagabend empfehlen ihnen die
runde bei maybrit illner hochspannend
die politik macht auf die unsicherheit
bleibt und wir danken für das interesse
und sagen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren seit
wochen ist es in aller munde das ist so
wahnsinnig trocken ist also schauen wir
uns doch mal die regenmengen hier
beispielhaft an der station berlin tegel
der vergangenen zwölf monate an
da sieht man das ist zum beispiel im
februar recht viel geregnet hat ähnlich
wie im juli 2009 10
wir müssen das natürlich aber im
vergleich setzen zu dem was im
klimatologischen mittel der jahre 1981
bis 2010
normalerweise unterkommt und da sieht
man eben ganz deutlich dass es einige
monate gab den hat es deutlich weniger
geregnet wie zb august 2009 10 oder eben
jetzt auch hier im april 2020 also
freuen wir uns nach wie vor über den
regen der dfl der kommt von westen heran
weil es ein kleine teams die uns da
immer wieder mit regen versorgen und
dabei bleibt es bei uns auch relativ
kühl und das ändert sich in den nächsten
tagen nicht es kommen jetzt die neuen
regenwolken im äußersten westen an
dazwischen zwischen dem abziehenden
regen hier im osten tut sich aber eine
kurze regenpause auf und dieses neue
regenband das liegt am morgen früh hier
zwischen der nordseeküste und dem
pfälzer wald und zieht im laufe des
tages weiter nach osten
danach gibt es etliche regenschauer und
gewitter aber zwischendurch kann sich
doch auch mal kurz die sonne zeigen
in den gewitter gibt es auch stürmische
böen die temperaturen der nacht liegen
so zwischen vier und zehn grad morgen
über tag gibt es maximal 11 bis 19 grad
und wechselhaft geht es erstmal weiter
schönen abend noch